you're watching the daily climate show
on
sky news on today's programme families
could be given
cash to help offset their energy bills
under plans being considered by the
government
the sinking brothel of bangladesh we
report from banishante
where climate change has pushed many
women into prostitution
and how your pension could help save the
[Music]
planet
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
now the government is considering
paying families to help them offset the
rising cost of gas bills
and encourage a switch to green energy
now around
19 million homes in the uk need to be
made
more efficient in order for the
government to hit its 2050 net
zero target now under the proposed
scheme low and middle income
families will be paid a set amount to
compensate
for increases in gas bills that will
come from the drive to cut emissions
it would also be funded by a new carbon
tax
and all families would be paid the same
regardless of their individual emissions
it means households who switched to
cheaper green energy
would still get the full payment meaning
that they could pocket the difference
well here to explain more is our climate
correspondent hannah thomas peter
so hannah tell us more about how this
scheme might work
well this is as you said part of a
government strategy to
address a really big logistical problem
which is that we've got 19 million homes
in this country that need to essentially
be given
a green retrofit in the coming years if
the government is to have
any chance at all of hitting its net
zero emissions by 2050
target the one that we hear so much
about now
right now there's a really complicated
set of schemes and potential grants that
you can apply for if you want to get a
heat pump for example
or if you want to put special insulation
in your homes but there's not one
overarching homes and heating policy
just listen to one person we've spoken
to about the challenges
of green retrofits when you're sort of
doing it on your own without government
help
i would guess that the the renovations
so far are in the 10
000 to 20 000 pound range
i've done a lot of the work myself and
with the help of
friends and family so i imagine that it
could be
a bit more than that i would say that
this is a fairly small house
and there are much larger homes that
require a much deeper
retrofit so the cost can rise
so boris johnson knows that he has got
to find a way to incentivize green
behavior
and it's not just a practical problem
it's a political one as well this scheme
that the government
is considering is about making sure that
all those
new conservative voters in particular
low-income homeowners in particular
aren't suddenly faced with unreasonably
high costs
as this country races to go green
hannah thank you and you can find out
more about how the scheme would work on
our website just head to skynews.com
climate let's take a look now at the
day's other climate news and the
australian government says there are
grounds to appeal a judgment
declaring young people must be protected
from pollutants
from a coal mine expansion if approved
the judge said the country's environment
minister susan lay
must take reasonable care to avoid
causing personal injury or death
to those under 18.
the uk is ranked sixth in the world for
the share of electricity generated by
wind and solar
these renewables accounted for 29 of
britain's electricity production last
year according to analysis by the think
tank ember
electricity generated by wind and solar
has doubled over the last five years and
now provides almost a tenth of the
world's electricity
the co-op has introduced in-store
recycling across the uk
in a bid to reduce plastic waste the
launch of the recycling points
follows a successful trial in 50 stores
that saw
86 percent of customers use the service
crisp packets and yogurt lids are
amongst the items that
can be collected through the scheme
which also accepts food packaging from
other retailers
the university of bristol has become the
first university in the world to achieve
institutional green labs certification
it means the university's laboratories
are reducing the impact on the climate
through using
more efficient equipment and better
waste management
although labs are essential for climate
research they
have five times more environmental
impact
compared to office spaces
and the london symphonetta orchestra are
staging a concert
totally off-grid instead the performance
called houseslide will
be powered entirely by bicycles 16 bikes
will
be used to generate energy for the
performance which explores one woman's
journey
tackling the climate crisis cyclists
will need to pedal non-stop for 40
minutes during the show
which is held at london's royal festival
hall
bangladesh is one of the world's most
densely populated countries and is
hugely vulnerable to climate change
over a quarter of the population lives
on the coast that's around 45
million people and flooding caused by
rising sea levels and made worse by
cyclones
is a huge problem last year alone
4.4 million internal displacements in
the country
were caused by disasters now that number
accounts for people sometimes displaced
more than once
due to multiple extreme weather events
now we heard last week from the capital
dhaka where families are forced into
living in slums far from their
families and communities others end up
in even more difficult circumstances
some women on the run from rising sea
levels have been pushed into a life of
prostitution
and now near the village of bani shanta
they're in danger of being trapped by
the water again
from where skies katherine vitotse
reports
the name of this place is bani shanta it
means
a message of calm but on this narrow
strip of land there is little peace
these huts form one of the country's
oldest brothels
here women call themselves girls
many have been trafficked some because
of the impact of climate change
when pervin was 15 her family's coastal
home and farm were destroyed through
rising sea levels
the loss made the family desperate which
made pervin a target
for sex traffickers
legacy
around a hundred women work in bani
shanta
and although brothels are legal in
bangladesh they are still taboo
sex workers and their children are
hugely stigmatized
here at least there is a sense of
community
but climate change is eroding that too
their land is disappearing chipped away
by rising sea levels
and hit by a vicious cyclone last year
the chief madam here tells us they can't
move further back
they're stuck between a river that
floods them to the front
and behind a village that doesn't want
them and where they couldn't work
climate change affects us all but it
also
exposes vulnerabilities and affects some
so much more than others katarina
vertotsi sky news in banishchanter
bangladesh
and you can see more from bangladesh on
our weekly digital show we go behind the
scenes of katarina's trip to a country
on the front line
of the climate crisis that's available
on sky news social channels our app
and website now from going vegan to
reducing the amount of flights you take
many of us are making small changes to
the way we live our lives
to help save the planet but what about
choosing to go
green with your pension moving your
investments to sustainable funds
could have a far greater impact on the
environment according to the campaign
group
make my money matter now they estimate
that it could save
19 tons of carbon per year more than
double the average uk
carbon footprint well joining me now is
richard curtis
film director and co-founder of make my
money matter
welcome to you richard curtis you've
you're known of course for your film
directing so what's got you interested
in green pensions
oh look you know the other thing i've
done is um
i started red nose day and i'm a un
advocate for the sustainable goals and
i'm as passionate as most people you
know suddenly are about climate
and everything that we can actually do
about it rather than just hoping that
our
politicians take action faster and so i
got really interested in the issue
of financial footprint having an effect
on your
carbon footprint well yes and it's
perhaps not the most obvious weapon
against
climate change but what difference do
you think that having a green pension
can make
well it's incredible actually because
all the money that we've got in pensions
is invested i don't think when i started
looking into this i
knew even that which means that you have
a choice to invest in
all the companies all the things that
you can make a difference you know so
your money won't be contributing to
deforestation it'll be contributing to
renewable energy you know you'll be in a
affordable housing you'll be supporting
all sorts of things that can really help
the planet without doing anything apart
from making the initial
demand or choice to change your pension
into a sustainable one so
it's literally the biggest weapon that
most individuals have
to personally have an effect on climate
change
is it a complicated process though
switching your pension to
being sustainable how do you know
whether or not it is
well uh i mean your pension provider
knows
and uh it can be complicated it can be
easy my
instinct is that it's easy for people
who have financial advisors to say this
is what i want
most people have their pensions through
their companies and companies are
increasingly seeing that as part of
their
sustainable responsibilities so
the thing is to ask and with any luck
now
increasing number of pension providers
will say oh yeah well look if that's
what you want we won't give you a
default pension that may be in
arms and gambling and deforestation and
fossil fuels will give one which is in
renewable housing renewable energy
um you know sustainable food and all
those things so
it's it's part of a process that is
gradually becoming easier
well richard curtis really interesting
to talk to you thanks very much indeed
are you really welcome good to talk to
you that's everything from us for this
week but don't forget to check out
climatecast over the weekend
and in the latest episode find out what
climate change and donuts
have got in common you can find that
wherever you normally get your podcast
from
thanks for watching and see you next
[Music]
week